hey guys I'm Greg I'm John I'm going to
be doing a reaction today with it
Brianne from hit-or-miss movies but
before we do that we wanted to give a
shout out to today's video sponsor with
my homeboy John Full Sail University if
you've been following our channel for a
while then you have undoubtedly heard
the name Full Sail University if you
love film and you're looking to make
some movie magic of your own you're
gonna want to check these guys out it
smell industry is hard work but you know
what it's also exciting work and
incredibly reward it but if you don't
know how to get involved or what area
you'd like to work in even bull sail is
the greatest place to check out Full
Sail University offers a wider range of
degrees and courses both on campus and
online classes that allow you to explore
the filmmaking process from beginning to
finish so you can really figure out what
kind of work you're into like whether
you're an editor a director sound
engineer cinematographer or etc there's
knowledge and a chance to really
practice your craft just waiting for you
at full sail they have a cutting-edge
digital cinematography program so you
can keep up to speed with the latest
filmmaking technology and they also
offer courses in animation gaming mobile
technology and various other things as
well
Full Sail has a ton of graduates working
in the actual film industry today the
real the real ones such as major films
like Jurassic world frozen Avengers age
of Ultron minions
so if you're serious about a career in
filmmaking and you want to check out
more of these programs and opportunities
head on over to Full Sail dot edu slash
YouTube to find out more all right John
get the heck out of here I got a filmer
brand you bet
the
hey guys I'm Greg with hit-or-miss
movies miss movies yeah yeah my friend
Brianne I was on film therapy where we
got real
we got real we got very real what's the
other one series that feature feature
film yet with her Stacey and John
Humphrey my buddy you know why I made it
six degrees of feature film because it
was six degrees of Kevin Bacon so I
needed two words Oh having bacon honest
trailers The Princess Bride Bree have
you seen The Princess Bride have I seen
it I own it I have cosplay for it
my shoes Fred seven specific it's Fan
Appreciation Month it's screen shows a
feast and a reward our awesome fans
we're making the honest trailers that
you voted for here's your number four
choice currently like what number one
from the egg comes a satire of all those
sappy swashbuckling medieval love
stories that happened to be the best
sappy swashbuckling medieval love story
ever been taught to the film that every
kid is guaranteed to love with the title
that every boy is guaranteed to hate
made a book giving up a red label about
the same made-up books that the real
movie is based on wait is that right
gather round for a tale of epic romance
that kicks off a young boy's puberty is
this a kissing book not as kissing again
you know what hear that I don't mind so
much as a word story full of beautiful
heroes dashing roads and cunning
villains who probably sound a lot less
impressive when their words are coming
out of Peter Falk by the bonds applause
haha she's sure love happens every day
good love we're story about the power of
true love between Wesley the farm boy
turns pirate and Buttercup the farm
owning more funny turns princess of
winter
conspire to keep them apart nothing will
stop true love from bringing them back
together whether it's kidnapping my wife
single only me
dad dad cannot control of the fact that
he's kind of abusive habit of warning
Highness the fact that she's kind of a
pain bond boy polish like what's this
better not to see my face showing you
mean it's my morning the budget he's an
optimist and she's a pessimist not that
bad or the fact that they haven't spoken
in five years and the relationship was
based on him doing tours for children
extra spicy to net picture
[Music]
yep looks like too well to me but this
what Methodist romance prepared for
plenty of action to go around the
co-learning really polite action a
better on purpose I don't have to rip
you'll put down your well console down
my sword and try and kill each other
like civilized people
where no danger is too great that you
can't carry on a polite conversation
you are one thank you as worktops become
tux and though enemy he is too vile that
you can't have a nice chat while they're
trying to kill you lies to not become
well-spoken sir
truly you have a dizzying intellect why
should that make such a good run
I guess that's exciting so settle in one
more time for the action romance comedy
drama kids will be for adults that you
probably never saw in theaters but
rewatched on VHS so many times that you
can quote every line not just because
it's great but because every character
repeats their little catchphrase like a
hundred times as you wish story
Zorro Pirate's Booty hi my name is what
my name in a coma coil obey Danny to
beatings ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha go to
11 granny says cheesy music
and offer you some troubles but come on
who cares
this movie is amazing Adventure Time why
don't they make satirical fairy tales
anymore with romance and action and
jokes and a big giant guy all right be
sure to subscribe for more mystery the
wow sounds right up in the air grace be
I'm to help requesting this movie and
adding to the awesomeness of Fan
Appreciation Month we boy boy boy boy
they really uh they did paint things in
a different light so I like it when when
screen junkies does that I like the
women yeah comedy but it's also
complimentary exactly a complementary
comedy because this by no means like
ruins the film or makes you see it in a
different way where you're like oh oh it
was crap like I did it real it was bad
you know I like to be adding of the
music when he's taking the picture down
that was pretty yeah yeah that made me
chuckle or are like when they have a
John Bailey with the voices now when
he's doing the grandpa voice like over
the characters talking sure every think
about that what he's telling the story
man charity wasn't al out was saying
what happened to that guy you know
around kind of he was like in saw yeah
the last Saw movie it's where he's still
working and doing like television he was
just so cool back then you know as to be
at this and Prince of Thieves and that's
what I grew up I grew up I write about
it yes men in tights principally which
one's Prince of Thieves
I don't know that's a lot of my mom even
talked about that yeah Robin Hood men in
tights I grew up watching that and I
grew up watching this too and I forgot
how much I really adored this film this
is such a sweet sweet sweet sound the
whole romance with you know how it kind
of they don't really know each other
mildly abusive kind of negative and that
was a lot of edgy that's part of the joy
of the film is that they just love each
other natural
upon first sight you know I'm sure you
felt that way about your husband of
course
yeah right cool cool so I did and did he
does he ever say as you wish he does not
I say that like when I'm involved with a
girl I like when she as you wish and I
got from this movie oh of the main look
like amazing I got really quotes Big
Lebowski my love letters this assistant
Jimmy the money love all the other day
we got a rug and he's like this rug
really ties the room together I know
John Bailey man me I hope they never
replace it because I know he wasn't the
first honest trailer guy the first one I
believe went to went into the army oh he
did if I recall correctly hello well
that's that's important back correctly
that's what happened and then John
Bailey came about are you uncomfortable
right now
I'm not are you sure he was a little
uncomfortable you really look like
you're working your core - oh I should
be working my core as always I say I'm
sober that's a good posture that just
doesn't always work with that way more
presentable for Cameron it reminded me
of how I used to want to be like Cary
Elwes is character you know this guy
who's always cool and calm and confident
even when he's fighting
he's so okay with the situation and so
in control and he could just carry on a
casual conversation I feel like we don't
get action heroes like that you know we
don't that kind of it so serious all job
Rick for Jason Bourne's you know the
conversation piece is really the part
that makes it more charming exactly and
that the other characters do it too
whereas now we just did action and we
don't have that surprised I didn't
reference Billy Crystal Carol Kane isn't
it yeah yeah I didn't want to be
Buttercup though like you said you
wanted to be him yeah I wanted to be
Zorro and I think I wanted to be him -
yeah everyone wanted vanity Dario was
awesome he's is so cool I mean I wanted
to give him like she does but she's such
she's a weak character I didn't
necessarily want to be her I really wish
she got like more mainstream movies you
know it wasn't wire wire yeah yeah I
never looked at his
filmography I know but he's like doing
some other stuff maybe he's like you
know what I love acting but I really
love poetry
now he's writing poetry that's true I
mean I think he tried transitioning more
to dramas too
when I was at age or stage I think I
think he's a theatre guy we make sense
he's British British people tend to be
theater do what he's British
yeah he's British did you know that did
you know this Graham all right guys well
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe today but
more importantly you should check out
hit or miss movies she has some awesome
awesome content on there you know it's
very different than a lot of other movie
channels and I knew that from watching
your videos with them especially going
on it I was like there's no other movie
channels that have discussions to this
type of level and I feel like you guys
deserve way more subscribers you guys
put in a lot of hard work your videos
yeah they tend to be pretty long but
they are because it's a podcast 6-degree
the feature film is a pop yeah true as
well I'm it's on iTunes you can find it
there we do do it live on Wednesdays at
10:30 most of the time that's our that's
the time that we start and so we have a
live chat that's going on I like to say
that our Channel most movie channels
talk about like the trunk of the tree
and the leaves of the tree and the
branches of the tree and we talk about
the roots of the tree Wow yeah at least
with soul therapy for sure mm-hmm
we talk about the importance of the
movies how they affect us what that's
the only way I can I bet we're doing so
much right